[Music]
whoo good thing they Big Bend us excuse
me Elizabeth towered us in the very
first second of the movie otherwise how
would we have ever known we were in
London also obvious painting is obvious
you know how you know this movie is old
it opens with 2.5 minutes of credits
over a cityscape
all over all the one-man band
instruments seem to match up pretty well
that accordion line continues throughout
this entire song even though he stops
playing at several times ladies and
gents Pollak oh boy
bird is a Dick Van Dyke to the British
accent I feel which do happen all happen
before Disney reveals its own production
slogan over a half century ago the clues
were there the whole time five minutes
in and this movie is still king around
Oh Oh breaking the fourth wall when
you're not a Deadpool or Jay and Silent
Bob movie hey cherry tree line they need
the trees after this street actually
[Music]
you guys are sending a portion of the
profits to kesserling and Capra on the
rest of the Arsenic and Old Lace gang
with this ripoff Teddy Roosevelt for
dick right those little beasts have run
away from me for the last time you're
quitting as a nanny because the kids
keep running away from you seriously you
are nanny lady and you have patience as
a non nanny human and you're stupid for
not putting bells and the kids are tying
them to a bedpost how does a bastard
orphan son of a whore and a Scot wait I
think I got my wires crossed again
[Music]
that's argument with that one be that as
it may I do not just can quit or leave
Jesus stop being polite about
interrupting or at least mr. banks is a
CodeRed you're goddamn right I did
asshole before even showing up on screen
I don't be curious to see how they
redeemed him later in the movie movie
makes the only good case I've ever seen
for having a homeowner's association QED
it's grand to be an Englishman in 1910
King Edward's on the throne it's the age
of men the patriarchy also FYI this
movie takes place roughly 21 years after
the events of the prestige which is a
much better movie despite what the
nostalgia diaper crowd in the comments
whatever you believe witness advice upon
learning his children are missing and
declaring he'll deal with it this father
goes straight to the telephone children
come here at once
look either they were obedient
subservient creepy robot children or
their rebellious turds that keep
ditching all the new nannies they cannot
be both she says this in full audio view
of the bank's parents take us down good
he then goes on to sing a couple hundred
words thereby creating the most
expensive classified-ad the world has
ever seen
there's so many words at the full page
goddamn at its worst
give us treats dogs if you once cold and
dominate us I didn't know we all James
wrote Mary Poppins holy SH old timey
Britain was a tough place to be a nanny
you had to worry about tiny frog cousins
in your bed pepper in your tea and wait
sounds like a single middle school
afternoon how are these kids driving
nannies away with lame stunts like this
pure unadulterated magic will now weigh
in and bump these children's futures by
telling Mary Poppins to visit them
because spoiled rich children are the
most deserving children on earth for a
visit from a magical fairy nanny not any
kids in Africa or Gary Indiana even in
the poorer parts of London nope these
rotten rich toddlers thanks to his
children's letter into exactly eight
pieces so why are there at least twice
as many pieces flying out of this Chim
Cheree gym guru you got some Wizard of
Oz in my Mary Poppins god damn the nanny
unemployment in London was off the
charts Nana side also no seriously
Poppins is using mob tactics here she
wants the job and needs other applicants
to go away fine resorting to physical
violence that's a felony this insert of
the obviously torn paper looks nothing
like the seemingly unblemished paper
she's reading from it's obviously there
so the audience will realize what's
going on but couldn't we and mr. banks
get that from the words alone close your
mouths please Michael we are not a
codfish why codfish I mean I suppose
like all fish they do open their mouths
a bit but if you wanted to be zoo
illogically accurate I think basking
shark is the way to go here right yeah
she's in the nursery of course I mean I
put it to work straightaway your kids
are like fifth graders you call their
room and nursery oh I see the nurseries
where they play not worthy nurse god I
hope they don't know us in here I don't
they don't nurse at all actually
basically Mary Poppins is a magician who
uses nannying as a way to find an
audience
she's Penn & Teller with an early
childhood education degree I much prefer
seeing all of my face at the same time
okay I was going to ignore it but I
can't anymore
this movie subtitles are wrong
consistently here the subtitle has her
saying at once instead of at the same
time just a second ago the wife said
what on earth are you doing I thought
you were interviewing nannies but the
subtitles skip the entire sentence what
on earth are you doing then she says I
would have muddled the whole thing but
the subtitles say muddled everything and
this is the anniversary edition the only
way these subtitles could be this bad as
if you use super old ones and then ran
them through google translate English to
Spanish and then back to English again
thing of beauty is a joy forever I will
take a cent off though for the pure
old-school movie magic at work here
okay the bag is huge inside we get it
real talk how do because that lamp
already lit without even a power cord
coming out of it and currently plugged
into nothing this makes my prestige joke
earlier seemed eerily prescient as
clearly Tesla is powering this lamp and
probably made her a carpetbag of magic
sighs and oh my god new fan theory the
prestige and Mary Poppins take place in
the same universe discuss amongst
ourselves after someone gives me a
cookie for coming up with this cute but
you know who was the same height as Mary
Poppins Charles Manson
she's singing the spoonful of sugar
helps the medicine go down song and I'm
left to wonder has anyone on this
production ever swallowed a spoonful of
granulated sugar even powdered sugar
because that is a nightmare of coughing
and agony also how much medicine are you
giving these kids per dose that you need
a whole spoonful sure to hide the taste
no lie these stuffed fake Robins moving
about awkwardly here gave me nightmares
like you would not believe damn it movie
the songs that voice
Julie freakin Andrews smoothie is pure
magic and even my cold dark heart has to
take a spoonful sins off for how joyful
this movie is roll supercalifragilistic
expialidocious movie fails to give
adequate take drugs now warning movie
and advertently inspires Roger Rabbit
hot Jesus would you look at the side
laughing whores that is a double wide of
a Clydesdale horse right there that's a
bunch of people in a horse costume
actually right did the animator even see
a horse before getting this job it's
like he drew a rhino and then removed
the horn
huge giant horse and the horse you rode
in on and promptly ate two turtles
totally tickled to transfer two
tremendously titanic troubadours toward
terra firma though truth told turtles
are terrible transportation too tired to
tread the tide typically translating to
tragic terminal tales
white up white up anyone who sits down
and instantly yells for a waiter is a
super douche
though I guess his outfit could also
told me the same thing
[Applause]
kazoos strew that - and simple have wage
that a winning and putin's and Gwendolen
set your are spinning dick Mandrake
forty two years before happy feet second
Warner Brothers fine an imagination
world we can somehow believe that he's
wearing the same pants and just pulled
them down a bit but I can't stop
thinking about where that waistline
would be if he pulled them back up at
least his shoulders right until I really
watch Mary Poppins I never realized how
much march of the Penguins ripped it off
this merry-go-round is weak it only has
four horses total hmm
even discount john c reilly here would
have to agree that as much good stuff as
there is in this painting adventure it
goes on for way too long I'm not saying
you cut everything out but did we really
need this boring fox hunt will be
predicts future by Disney's scooping up
Fox and running away so does that make
these guys comcast no you can say it
backwards which is doshas alley XP is
too tragic caddy ruthless rupess
shouldn't be rebus or that matter you
just reversed the phrases and not the
letters up until super so I change it
there anyway shouldn't you have said
dosha Sally XP istic frantic Alice super
because if you're saying the whole thing
backwards it would be soo a Cordelia
exit cilia garlic ripest I'm just saying
this bit of showboating is complete
bullsh and we should never trust
anything Mary Poppins says or does again
one night I shouldn't do a girl girls
wife Carol domestic abuse is casual sure
Mary Poppins will somehow get the banksy
kids out of this street art but what are
the town's folk horses dogs and Turtles
gonna do I'm just seeing the movie yadda
yadda is the death of an entire
community and I'm not cool with it
[Music]
reversing ecology chien cook usually
fight like cats and dogs but today this
is such an obvious thinking we're just
talking about happens to occur just as
you're talking about a cliche that mrs.
banks looks to see it happening before
she has any way of knowing it's coming
alright I'm saying it
supercalifragilisticexpialidocious is
the 99 bottles of beer on the wall of
classic Disney movie songs it's only
enjoyed by those singing it and to
everyone else it's maddening whoops
don't you two stop come
down here this movie really almost
demands you take drugs right or at least
acknowledge those making it did but will
you bet anyone concerned that there's
still a table levitating over their
hands and the person who used their
apparent telekinetic powers to put it
there just left no one just me them
Jewish fellow to bitch movie has time
for this but tea parties on the ceiling
I ask you having tea parties on the
ceiling I love how he's offended by the
tea parties because of the uncouth
nature of having them on the ceiling
instead of the floor ignoring completely
the magic of how and why they are on the
ceiling goats pot goats but today to the
steps of can we get a spoonful of
interesting to help this depressing dirt
to go down and before you come at me
with that it's so beautiful
or it's the point of the movie nonsense
let me just ask you how many times you
couldn't get this song out of your head
if you're a huge popping head maybe
remember to feed the birds line other
than that this is a huge time-suck when
all we really need is for the banks
family to get to some bank see how much
do you think they spent on this giant
unused room the bank that has decorative
wooden columns and marble floors and
artwork throughout but otherwise has no
purpose whatsoever this song about
investing makes me want to waste money
on hookers lottery tickets and blow now
you may say that I started out wanting
to spend my money on those things and
you would be right but my point is that
it didn't change my mind but song didn't
work and that's on the song considering
it's barely been 10 seconds since the
first person asked to pull their money
how on earth did all these monopoly men
hear about it so quickly hey you're the
one that had a penguin trying to bed
Julie Andrews movie so don't come at me
with your superiority wait I may have
misunderstood oh no it's so it's
conveniently mary's day off and your
employees give you lip and refuse to do
what you ask you're just gonna let grimy
chimney sweep guy look after your kids
for the evening so you can go egg the
Prime Minister's house I know mr. banks
takes all the grief for his aloofness
but mrs. banks a much better eel
be careful so Mary Poppins is taking
your day off until she's needed for the
big rooftop dance number I see how it is
dear god I hope she stops with the nones
I'm already feeling very uncomfortable
this chimney march dance is depressing
us by the time it ended I hated puppies
the hell did Mary Poppins do this or our
chimney sweeps magical creatures that
only need a head to survive this steps
on for some time I remove all the sins
if just one of these fuckers tripped and
fell and this movie became a surprise
PSA about the dangers of dancing on
rooftops you never knew how large the
chimney sweep mafia Wallis did yeah hot
damn this movie could be so much shorter
if we just trimmed the rooftop dancing a
bit holy first of all I would like to
make one thing quite clear I never
explain anything movie speaks directly
to a confused audience mr. banks sings
about how it's all Mary Poppins fault
and his world was calm and well ordered
before she showed up that's a bald-faced
lie his kids were little hellions kids
feeling rebellious and his wife was
caught up in the suffragette movement
that he hates and when your little tykes
are crying you haven't time to dry their
tears shaming mr. banks
[Music]
this is a 90 minute movie that takes two
hours and 20 minutes we really need a
full three minutes of this mr. banks
fired man walking nonsense I could have
watched that whole skippity video again
in that time and through all the tea
overboard this made the tea unsuitable
for drinking even for Americans oh come
on that was a funniest joke in the whole
movie but this movie won't let banks get
credit for it because his audience is a
bunch of stuffy old dorks what a ripoff
so to fire him they destroy his umbrella
and hat unless the company paid for
those why would they have Bank should
file charges on these dicks that's his
personal property what would happen to
me may I ask if I loved all the children
I said goodbye to you be a decent human
being and not a sociopath so have them
drag the river there's a nice spot there
by Southwark bridge popular with jumpers
what the fuck it's true
in a moment he will show them that he
mended the family kite but since he was
fired precisely at 9:00 p.m. and they
had long enough this morning to call the
police are we suggesting it took him all
night to pay some newspaper over those
holes and so they lived happily ever
after until a few months later when they
all died with pneumonia from being
destitute and unable to pay for health
care because flying kites wasn't
considered adequate payment rest in
peace banks family rest in peace he left
an opening for a new partner or he gets
his job back because his random unfunny
joke killed his former boss by the way a
spoonful boss perhaps the plot of ice go
down in the most convenient way
I hardly think a few birds are going to
bring about the end of the world did you
get sacked sad certainly not I am never
sad you find the fun and snap I don't
know want to go Oh blue and I are just
headed over to the newsstand do you want
to come along which is doshas alley XP
istic tragically ruthless what's that
Lassie you feel sick ass apposite